we all remember the struggle in college
right with the rank going up all across
the valley well some students tell me
there isn't any help available for them
each one doing what they can to get
ahead
it would be amazing to be on campus like
it would make studying so much easier i
met sue anderson in between classes as
she is wrapping up her fourth year at
unlv she says her education is expensive
and so is housing across the street it's
like fifteen hundred dollars for rent
they have sewage problems they have
gunshots it's not safe according to
unlv's website residence halls costs for
first-year freshmen pay between 29 to 3
300 dollars per semester upper class
living will cost 924 dollars for a
2-bedroom and 749 dollars for a
four-bedroom school leaders say those
rates haven't changed in several years
which were approved by the board of
regents being on campus is cheaper than
anywhere else in the valley right now
i'm living with three roommates and i'm
paying almost 900. las vegas native
lindsey perea says going to school full
time and having a part-time job was
still not enough to pay for her housing
she says her parents had to step in it's
expensive it's terrible
it's stressful unlv's university support
team is available to help students with
housing transportation child care and
even food insecurities this student
telling us he found a solution to his
problem i work as a residential
assistant for the campus so they cover
the room and board as well as the meal
plan as well as pay you students say
college is a sacrifice which will pay
off in the end in the meantime the
struggle to get by anderson says is
rough i went to buy a cup of coffee and
it was like six dollars like is this
worth it
that coffee is always worth it all right
csn is a non-residential campus but they
tell us it offers student aid through
the student emergency fund which is up
to 500 on a 12-month basis now nothing
specific on housing assistance though
well students also say scholarships are
a great resource christian concert has 8
news now